so much of our early understanding of
the characters
worlds and relationships of mass effect
is defined by
one conflict or another the rachni war
the geth war the krogan rebellions the
genophage so it only makes sense that
our understanding of how
humans fit into milky way society is
also defined by conflict
to the turians and most other aliens
it's called the relay 314 incident
but humans refer to it as the first
contact war
but let's back up a bit in 2148 35 years
prior to the events of mass effect 1
humanity discovers evidence of an
ancient sentient alien species called
the protheans on mars
if you want a bit more context on who
and what the protheans were
you can watch our previous mass effect
lore video anyway this discovery
accelerates humanity's technological
advancements when it comes to space
travel
the ruins also mention an interstellar
highway composed of technology called
mass
relays which allows near instantaneous
interstellar travel
and apparently one of those mass relays
is in the solar system
a year later humanity discovers that
what was previously believed to be one
of pluto's moons
is in fact the mass relay mentioned in
the prothean ruins with a bit of work
humanity reactivates the relay allowing
them to travel to the arcturus system
where they find even more relays
thinking nothing of it humanity starts
reactivating every relay they can
find traveling far and wide across the
milky way galaxy
eight years later in 2157 humanity
reactivates mass relay 314.
as it turns out the turians witnessed
the deed and opened fire because
activating dormant relays is
highly illegal in citadel space why is
it illegal
well that's a very long story and a
whole other video but basically
activation of a previously dormant relay
over 2000 years prior
led to the discovery of the raknai which
led to the rachni war which led to the
uplifting of the krogan
which led to the krogan rebellions which
led to the genophage which is why the
turian salarians and krogan
all have rather tense relationships with
each other there's
so much more to those stories but that's
the basic gist of why the citadel
outlawed reactivation of dormant relays
it could potentially
lead to the discovery of a dangerous
species now
turians are nothing if not sticklers for
the rules which is why they opened fire
and what they perceive to be someone
breaking the law
small problem humanity has no idea that
what we are doing
is wrong we have never encountered a
living sentient species before
no one had told us the rules so what
could have been an easily explained
misunderstanding
instead erupted into all-out conflict
that humanity would come to call
the first contact war humanity's
response to being attacked is to get
recon on the threat
and humans being humans we don't just
send scouting probes into terrain space
to spy on our enemy
we send in scouting probes armed with
nuclear fusion
warheads you know just in case a probe
is discovered and needs to be destroyed
to avoid the turians learning more about
us
thankfully no probes are discovered
unfortunately
those warheads are still floating around
in turian space by the time of the
events of mass effect 1
a dirty little secret that humanity
hopes the rest of the galaxy never
discovers
though humanity claims a few victories
in the war the turians take the
advantage early on pushing humanity back
to sean xi
the human colony established just
outside mass relay 314
the turians then simply set siege to the
colony bombarding it with orbital
strikes
though the leader of the colony's
garrison general williams puts up a
strong effort
he ultimately surrenders making him the
first human leader
to ever surrender to an alien threat
williams would be demoted and face
prejudice from military command for the
rest of his very short career
as a result and the stigma against him
would pass on to his son
who also enlisted william's
granddaughter ashley williams would
inherit this family curse next
breeding her blunt it's me against
everyone else attitude
and initial discomfort at working
closely with aliens like tali liara
garris and rex
it's not racism not really members of
their species will always be more
important to them than humans are
but enough of that believing they have
won the turians relax
only to be surprised by the appearance
of humanity's second fleet
at this point the citadel council
notices that a fairly
major conflict is brewing under their
noses and chooses to step
in negotiating peace talks between
humans and turians
and ending the three-month war humanity
finally learns that the milky way is
inhabited by many different species
most of whom coexist peacefully under
the leadership of the citadel council
after seeing that humanity has a knack
for waging war
the council views humans as a much
needed asset and ally
and invites them into the galaxy-wide
alliance humanity accepts
it isn't a smooth transition though
after hearing about how humanity's first
contact with an
alien race went down most species begin
to view all humans as bullies prone to
violence this perception is not helped
by humanity's aggressive push to have
footholds across the galaxy
and a dominant voice in the citadel
humans face extreme prejudice from other
species for
years especially from turians like saren
who had lost loved ones to the war
pro-human groups begin popping up in
response most notable
is terra firma a human political party
which opposed humanity's integration
into milky way society
and cerberus a human paramilitary group
that works to improve humanity's
standing
in the face of alien prejudice to ease
the tension the council orders the
tyrians to pay reparations to humanity
eventually the two species become trade
partners further improving relations
between them
to symbolize the friendlier relationship
between their two governments
despite the continued strain between
veterans of the war humans and turians
decide to work together
putting their combined military might
and engineering architecture into one
starship that ship would become the ssv
normandy a symbol of what can be
achieved when mankind works together
with aliens
instead of trying to kill them and its
first mission is the opening chapter
of mass effect 1 and that's the history
behind story of and ramifications of the
first contact war a war that
in the grand scheme of things is still a
relatively recent conflict in the milky
way's history by the start of the mass
effect trilogy
hopefully you're now a little bit more
prepared to jump into mass effect
legendary edition
knowing why some humans on the ssv
normandy aren't immediately comfortable
serving alongside aliens despite what
the ship represents but speaking of
first contact which mass effect alien
species left the biggest first
impression on you
like you saw them for the first time and
just immediately wanted to know
everything about them personally i think
the quarians are fascinating and i loved
unearthing their history throughout the
trilogy and talking to tally
usually flirtatiously leave your answers
in the comments below and subscribe to
the channel for more mass effect lore
videos like this one
[Music]
[Music]
you